[Music]
okay everyone I'm so excited with Laura
Linney here Laura I absolutely love that
you're a big Funko fan were you so
excited to see you're finally a Funko
because that was amazing I couldn't
believe it I was really stunned does it
have the seal of approval from you oh
absolutely
you know I love Jason's and I love
Julia's
uses the three of them yeah no for sure
and it's exciting with this Premiere
happening here and I love that you're in
this cast with Kathy Bates and Maggie
Smith do you still get kind of
StarStruck at even names like that of
course are you kidding oh yeah we just
put that just a little closer feels a
little scary it scared me a little bit
it's a little scary just came at me a
little fast
um
um yeah I mean of course I mean they're
the best of the best and you know
they've they've given us all such
amazing work over a lifetime of you know
accomplishments so sure yeah and it's
interesting too I love where your career
trajectory has gone and was there
something different though with Ozark
and the amount of exposure like did you
notice anything different from day to
day
you mean as far as recognition the
recognition Factor you know not really
I've got to tell you I think I've just
been kicking around so long now that
it's it's certainly another group of
people it's another fan base for Ozark
but you know I think fortunately I've
been working a long time so they're the
Love Actually people and they're the
John Adams people they're the tales of
the city people there's the you know so
it's um but it's it's I adore I adore
those are I absolutely adored it do you
see we could have possibly a Wendy bird
spin-off could you see a world where
that happens I can't
so what do you want the fans of this
film that see it to take away the most
from the miracle Club you know we have
I love it so she's one of us everyone
thank you Laura for joining me I hope
I'm talking my pleasure thank you so
much